I'm David Wilkes and I am an assistant scout master with troops 68 in Dallas,
Texas. This edition of the scout master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Love what you do in, Clark, Keep it up.
And now the old scout master:
How'd? you've been a scouter for a while.
You realize that a lot of things in scouting should go without saying.
okay, that you should step back and let scouts lead, and that in doing that
you're going to endure a little bit of chaos and uncertainty at times.
There are some things that do not go without saying,
For instance, everything that a scout needs on a camping trip.
none of that goes without saying,
And a lot of it doesn't go even if you do say:
Hey, this is podcast number 291..
Welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
We heard from Todd Rabie, who's a scout master with troop 400..
He says: I've been listening to your podcast and I think I've listened to over
a hundred in about three weeks. Wow, Ooh, that could be dangerous,
Todd, be careful. Uh, I do plan on becoming a backer because I think you are
doing the greatest thing since sliced bread.
Your website and podcasts are great
And what you're doing is awesome. Thank you so much. Well, thank you, Todd.
I don't know if we can out do sliced bread, but we're certainly going to give it a
shot. Okay, This past week
republished an article about three kinds of leadership, based on things said by
the founder of scouting, Baden Powell, and Lao Zai,
who's an ancient Chinese philosopher,
And even though they wrote, uh,
centuries apart in different parts of the world,
they kind of called out the same three types of leadership styles.
But anyway, check out that article if you get a chance.
John Collins commented on that article.
Thanks for the gentle- or not so gentle- reminders about leadership.
Timothy nurse thought it was a great article.
Christian said: good info.
Last year I wrote a skip for my weeblos- one dead- called the three patrol
leaders, which dealt with three different leaders trying to get the
same patrol to do the same thing.
but using three different leadership styles actually falls right in line
with what you're saying here. That's a.
that sounds like an interesting skit, Doesn't it?
Maybe I can get Christian to send that in. and Ken Donahue tweeted that
day: We're excellent information. Well, thanks everybody.
I'm glad you enjoyed that article. I'm glad that you find it useful
If you've been hanging around for a while. you know,
every week I try to get a couple of live chat sessions in over at
scoutmastercgcom.
If you keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed,
I will announce when we're going to be live.
It's usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings and you can come ahead and
join us and we chat about everything.
Sometimes it's pretty serious stuff and sometimes it's just the weather.
In addition to the many frequent fliers who check in with me every week-
Eric, who's a scoutmaster in Erie, Pennsylvania,
Brian Bush, who is a scoutmaster in Baldwin, Missouri,
and Kevin Kay, who's the cubmaster of pack 464 in Manuka,
Illinois, all checked in on the chat for the first time this week
And we certainly appreciate hearing from you. So come on over.
Like I said, keep an eye on the Facebook and Twitter feeds for live chat
announcements. Come on over and join us. It's great fun.
Now, next summer, I am going to be going back to Condorsteg
Condorsteg International Scout Center in Condorsteg, Switzerland.
Now, if you've never traveled to Switzerland before,
Condorsteg is in what's called the Bernie's Overland
and it's just a magical place to visit.
Plus, the International Scout Center that was founded back in the 1920s
is a wonderful place to visit.
It's kind of like a continuous mini world jamboree all summer long.
Every week there's oh three or four hundred scouts from all over the world
are visiting, And next summer will be my third trip
And I want to invite you to come along.
I've been able to provide the opportunity for my scouts to take advantage
of this incredible experience, and I'll take you right along with me.
The days for the trip are July 16th through the 23rd,
and I will have a link in the post that contains this podcast
about how you can participate.
If you want to bring a group, that's fine.
If you just want to come ahead yourself, that's fine too.
So that's Condorsteg 2016..
Don't miss it. It's going to be great fun.
I need to ask everybody a favor.
I need your help.
The blog and the podcast started back in 2005..
It's 10 years ago now and I didn't plan on what's happened.
I didn't plan this at all.
I just started blogging and then we added the podcast and then it just kind of exploded,
And I'm really pleased that people from all over the world
tell me the information that we share is useful,
And I hear from a lot of folks every week,
and it's heartening to know that I'm able to lend them a hand.
So what I'm asking in return is that you support the podcast
and the blog by becoming a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
It's really easy to do.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page.
You'll find a number of options for making a voluntary,
one time kind of subscription payment to help me keep things up and running.
The money we get from backers goes to the expenses of producing the blog
and the podcast,
And this week I want to thank Bruce Colkeback, Eric Morphy, Josh Kamoli
and Jim Gilligie, who became backers since last week's podcast.
Once again, real simple to do.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page
and become a backer. this week
I'll be sure to thank you personally on our next podcast.
Well, in this week's podcast I got a couple of really good email questions
to answer, and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
On the beat boy, beat boy. yeah, you are always on the beat boy, beat boy.
I'll hang it in the street boy, street boy.
We will dance into the beat boy, beat boy. yeah,
You're my favorite all time boy Scout.
He's my favorite all time boy Scout.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Now let's see. oh, this is going to be anonymous week
With the email questions. a couple of you know reasonably sensitive situations
that people email me about, and both of them wanted to remain anonymous.
Well, the first question I got is about a Scout who said he just doesn't have time
for Scouts anymore and he wants to quit,
But his mom is insisting that he continue on in Scouts.
So his mom wants him to get Eagle.
He says he doesn't really feel it's a realistic goal for him
and he's not sure how anyone could do it if their heart's not in it.
He's pretty frustrated with the whole thing
and is pretty torn as to what to do.
The person that sent me the email said
we told him that being a Scout is a big responsibility
and if he doesn't feel he can do it he needs to tell his mom,
and I don't think it helped.
The Scout is a great kid
and I'm sure he's tried to reason with his folks,
but they push him very hard.
So how do we resolve this situation?
Well, you know something.
you said something there that kind of stuck out:
Being a Scout is a big responsibility.
I don't know when that happened.
My understanding is that being a Scout
is about adventure and fun and hanging out with your pals.
You know, at least from the Scout's perspective,
that's what it ought to be.
Scout's advance is a natural result of doing those things right.
It's challenging,
but a big responsibility really.
I mean, did somebody change this around when I wasn't looking?
I wouldn't cast it in that light
because I really don't think Scouting is a big responsibility.
I think it's a lot of fun.
Now, if parents are really pushing a Scout
and he's feeling really stressed out,
really no big deal.
You're going to get out of Scouting whatever you put into it.
And if you're doing lots of other things
and you aren't able to put 110% into this,
that's no big deal.
Let's figure out how that's going to work
And with the age of the Scout in question,
he's got loads of time to work on Eagle
And I would tell him,
given your abilities and the kind of Scout you are,
it will probably be one of the easier things that you do.
How do I know to say that to the Scout?
based on the email that I got,
He's unsure about taking on a position of responsibility
and that he can do it well.
And just that little piece of knowledge
means that this Scout is aware enough
that if he's going to take on a position of responsibility,
he wants to do it well.
So that tells me an awful lot about this individual,
And I would tell him that taking on a position of responsibility
doesn't need to be a big giant deal.
It can be pretty simple really.
What would you like to do?
What do you have time to do?
What would you really get a kick out of doing?
Can you instruct some of the newer Scouts?
How about showing up at some Den meetings to help out?
But I can't go to Den meetings
because, jeez, I've already scheduled out
and I have to make all the troop meetings.
and I would tell him: hey, look, no problem,
Skip the troop meetings.
We'll figure out what that looks like
and we'll agree on what fulfills the requirement
for a position of responsibility
and being active with the troop.
Yeah, but I can't go camping all the time.
Hey, that's really no problem either.
Let's figure out what trips you can make
in the next few months
and you don't have to be there
every single time that we open the door.
But my mom is pushing really hard
and she's going to push me to be involved
in everything that I can possibly be involved in,
and she just doesn't understand
that I've got a lot of other things on my plate.
Look, you know what? how you and I figure out
just how much time you have to devote
to scouting over the next few months,
and let's do this a few months at a time. okay,
You can take what we decide to your mom
and explain that this is what we decided,
and if you want me to explain it to her, I'd be happy to.
If I'm going to be an Eagle Scout,
I need to get a pile of merit badges.
Well, you have X number of months, okay,
So let's say the scout was 15..
That means he has 36 months,
and if he had absolutely no merit badges,
that means he needs to earn one
about every two months or so,
But he probably has some merit badges already.
So figuring out, like you know,
a benchmark for earning merit badges-
that shouldn't be too difficult.
And merit badges for this guy,
who's obviously pretty sharp
and is academically talented,
are going to be pretty simple.
The biggest challenge is going to be finding
and meeting with counselors.
But let's see what merit badges you have now,
what you need, and we'll start picking away
the best of the ones that are required for Eagle.
But, man, then I got to do an Eagle project
and that's just going to be a killer.
Look, the Eagle project doesn't have to be a killer.
It just sounds like a big giant deal
and it's important- okay,
But it doesn't have to be this massive
undertaking.
There is a lot of paperwork, for sure,
and that's a lot of times
the most challenging thing.
But you're a first-class scout now.
You have four months to star, six months to life.
We can start thinking about Eagle projects now.
You can start doing some research-
You're not under the gun here-
And then, when you become a life scout,
you'll have a very solid idea of
what you're going to do and we'll start pulling things together.
So at this point,
all of this should sound pretty doable, right?
I know mom's pushing you
and it's something you really don't want to do
at this point. I get that,
but I would suggest that your perspective
may have changed
during our conversation here.
I think you'll be fine.
Let's have a plan
and start doing our best to sticking to it.
Let's stay focused on having
a great time with your pals and doing the things that
you really do like about scouts
And the other stuff will come along. naturally
It's important, but you're going to
sail through most of it. Millions of scouts
have and you'll get a lot of help
and support. Yeah, but I'm really
worried about all the time it's going to take.
Well, look, I'm not worried about that at all.
You bring the scout oath and law
and the other things you've learned in scout,
all those other activities you do.
Because I'm talking to a scout
who's playing sports and is involved in a couple
of other extracurricular activities
in school. right, He's likely to have
a leadership role in the sport that he's playing.
He's likely to have a leadership
role in some of the other extracurricular
activities he's doing. So my job
is to figure out how to
make this work
for this individual scout.
My bet is is that there
is absolutely no time
where he's just kind of sitting around the house
staring at the ceiling. He's a busy guy
and he's got six different things going on,
so that sounds like an
Eagle Scout to me And my job
is figuring out how to make that happen
for him. He's caught in a big
schedule. He's caught with a lot of pressure
from many different things and his parents-
and he hasn't been through all this
before. I have many, many times.
I have a better perspective than he has
and I can sit down with him
and I can talk through these things
and we're going to figure out a way
to make this happen. And then,
once we've got our plan sketched
out, we're going to talk a lot
because it's going to be challenging.
I'm not talking about knocking off all the challenges.
I'm just talking about making it
possible for an individual scout-
and there are going to be problems along
the way. We're going to set up a plan right
and then the plan is going to fall apart and we're going to have to reassemble it. but
we can get things
sorted out And I'm going to tell the scout:
what usually happens is you're going to get
disappointed in something and then you're going to hide out
and you're not going to want to talk to me because
you feel like you've let me down or something.
don't worry about that. The most important
thing is you don't ever
feel like this is all too much. So
we have to communicate on a regular basis.
So that's my answer
to the question: You've got a scout
who's way over scheduled, whose parents are
pressuring him.
What do you do to help him resolve that?
Well, first of all,
it is possible I've had some
incredibly busy guys
who had a lot of parental pressure
and, taking into account all
the things that they're doing,
the pressure they're getting from home,
sitting down and saying, alright, look,
let's change your perspective on this, because
you're seeing this one way.
but you need to understand
there is not just one way for this to
happen. There's lots of different ways.
So we're going to come up
with a plan that works for you. That's really
where we get to the way of
some resolution and the scout goes back
to having fun in scouts and being able
to have that time in scouting,
kind of as a respite from
all of the other pressures
that are going on. What about just telling
the parents off? right?
Well, good luck with that. And you notice
here, at no time do I think
that I need to tell the parents off.
I don't. People, families
are different. Families do things
differently. There are all kinds of parenting styles.
There are all kinds of families
and if you want to start messing around
with the dynamics of
a family and the way parents parent
their children. what you're doing basically
is like taking a fine Swiss
watch, opening the back and looking and seeing
that things are ticking and moving around
in there, and then you get like a screwdriver
and you try and fix
the watch. You know that
that's not going to work because you don't know
what's going on in there. You know you have
maybe a basic idea, but you're
going to mess something up more than you're going to fix
it right. I found out that
families are kind of that way.
You see things ticking and moving
and you think you may understand what's going on,
but as soon as you try to fix
something like that, you're going to find-
you're going to find out- that you really
don't understand much of anything about what's going
on. So sit down with that scout,
help them work it out,
help them develop a perspective
where they can get back
to enjoying scouts and having fun
and still achieve those
things that they have their eyes on. This
next email
came from a
scouter who said: I was recently called out
as an adult candidate
for the order of the arrow. Unfortunately,
my son,
though eligible, was not elected
as a candidate. Now
I value spending time with my wife and
children. I have pretty busy
schedule. I have few
non-work activities that don't include
my family. From what I can understand,
membership in the order of the arrow
comes with the expectation
that I'm going to be active.
I'm pretty troubled by the concept
of leaving my son behind
on weekends to go
and do OA activities.
I don't know if you've run across this
before, but I could certainly use some
advice. Well, the
order of the arrow can be a bit of a
puzzle. Now, it would have been better
if, before you were nominated
as an adult candidate, somebody had
asked if you would be able to accept
the nomination and kind of explained
what the obligations were going to be.
because if you look at the order of the arrow materials
right, adults are
nominated- quote- based
on their ability to perform the necessary
functions to help the order
fulfill its purpose
and not for recognition
of service, including
current or prior positions.
selected adults must be an asset
to the order because of demonstrated
abilities and must provide
a positive example for growth
and development of youth members of the lodge.
So your nomination to the
order of the arrow should be based
on the fact that you'll be a good contributing member.
It's not an honor.
ok, in the same way that
it is for a scout, right? It's not
about. well, you know, you've served
scouting for a long time and you're pretty good
guys, so we're going to honor you with being a
member of the order of the arrow. No, basically
it's: hey, here's
a scouter who has a proven track record,
who can make a contribution to help the youth
members of the lodge. That's why we
nominate adults to lodge
membership. So adults are nominated
to the order of
the arrow through the troop committee
and that nomination process should
be fairly transparent.
So I would tell your committee chair
that while you appreciate nomination,
you can't in all good
consciousness accept it at this time
and explain. you know I don't
have the time to put into this now,
while my son is not involved. when my son
becomes involved I'm happy to accept the
nomination. Committee can then
withdraw your nomination and nominate
another adult in your place, if that's possible.
I can't say I've run into this
before, because what we try to do
before we nominate adults
for the order of the arrow,
we inform all the eligible adults
that they are indeed eligible
for nomination as an adult
to a membership in the order of the
arrow and ask if they'll be able
to accept that nomination before we
make a final decision, And I think
that's a good practice to follow
and you won't end up in a situation
like the one in this email. Now,
although I haven't run into this, I doubt
that you're alone. I'm pretty sure plenty
of other scouts have found themselves
on the horns of this particular dilemma.
it's not your fault. the committee
really should have asked you before
they nominated you and they should
certainly understand that you're
not able to take this on right now.
After I sent that advice,
I heard back from this scouter
and they said I spoke with the scout master,
who generally wants me to accept
the candidacy and become an ordeal member.
his counsel was to act
as an example in a positive model
and inspire the boys
to man up and strive
to make the cut next year.
I think this entire dilemma might have been avoided
if more troops incorporated this plan
for the order of the arrow elections
and asked adults ahead of time
if they would be able to accept the nomination.
and while I'm on the subject,
we have a lot of younger scouts
and a 10 minute pep talk by two strange OA members
and then expecting 11
or 12 year olds to make an intelligent,
informed judgment when they get a ballot
doesn't seem to be a very realistic idea.
we had a room full of deer
in the headlights, stairs, shrugs,
and the election
to me was more a popularity contest
than one made on merit.
well, I got a couple of things to say and reply to that.
first of all,
a scout master who says things like
man up and make the cut,
really, I mean, come on
to 11 and 12 year old boys-
that's not likely to inspire
so much as discourage,
because that is a very aggressive way
of saying you are not a man
and I'm disappointed in you.
I know boys certainly take it that way
and so far as you're
becoming an ordeal member,
to somehow model
for them or encourage them
to quote: man up
and strive to make the cut next year,
no, no,
I don't go for that,
because the way adults
are nominated for the order
and the way scouts are elected
to the order are two
totally different things.
I've fielded many concerns about
all kinds of elections-
not just OA elections-
being popularity contests,
and I'm a little puzzled by that,
because every election,
at least in some measure, is exactly
not a popularity contest,
at least every election I've ever participated in,
in scouts and out,
and we also need to be real about an 11
or 12 year olds ability to make an intelligent,
informed judgment.
I mean, it's almost a contradiction in terms,
isn't it? They're 11 or 12,
and what we may not understand
about scouts- even those younger scouts-
is that they can have a much better view
of who merits their vote than we do.
they definitely have a different perspective
of it, and the fact that
the whole process
wants them to make this decision should tell
you something. they're going to make their judgment
as an 11 or 12 year old, not as an informed,
intelligent adult. I mean,
if you remember being a boy- and I have to work
at that, but I can still
recall some things about it if I try-
there were very big parts of our lives
when we were much younger
that were totally opaque to adults.
I can remember plenty of boys
who, from an adult standpoint,
looked very worthy and deserving.
from a boy standpoint,
they were kind of mean and nasty when the adults
weren't around. you know what I'm talking about.
so I wouldn't say that they weren't thinking
when they voted. I think they were probably
thinking in the way an 11
or 12 year old boy would think
when they're faced with these kind of decisions, the best
we can do, and what we ought to do,
is call upon their developing sense:
scout oath and law. get them thinking and talking
about it. what do you understand about making
this decision? how does a scout
oath and law apply to it? and when we start
talking with them about those kind of things,
they understand a lot more than
we think they did. they often just
don't get a chance to tell us because nobody
asked them. so ask them about
it. so, like I said, the order of the arrow
can be a puzzling
if you don't understand the way that it
works and how adults are nominated
to the order. I don't get particularly
distracted by the order of the arrow.
it's a great thing for our scouts.
I've been happy to serve
in different capacities as an
adult member of the order of the arrow,
but I would say this: scout age boys
do not really need an excuse
to be competitive with one another
or yet another way to form
clicks or classify
each other. it's pretty much
elemental the way they're working to figure
out the world to begin with.
hopefully,
their experience in scouting
encourages them to grow out of
competing with and classifying
others and gets them to
think about who they are
and how they understand the scout
oath and law and put it effect into
their lives, and that's why
I am very careful
about placing too much
emphasis on things like
order, the arrow, elections and
helping scouts put things like this into
perspective. hey, if you have a question
for me, you can get in touch. it's
very easy to do and I'm going to tell you
how to do that in just a moment.
thanks for listening to this 291st
edition of the scout master
podcast. here's how you keep in touch.
go to scoutmastercgcom
and you can read all the blog posts there.
there's about 1700 of them in the index,
classified under different
subject headings and things like that.
there's obviously 290
other podcasts and
while you're at scoutmastercgcom,
there's a link you can click and become
an email subscribers, so you get an email
every time the blog or the podcast
is updated. a lot of folks follow
us through that vast
panorama of social media.
you can join the 10,500
folks who like scoutmaster blog on
Facebook. we have a chorus of
1300 tweeters tweeting along with us on
Twitter and you can pin
the Pultritudinous pictures
proffered publicly with
2400 other prolific
pinners on Pinterest. you can watch
us at scoutmastercg on YouTube.
and if you can't face Facebook
and if Twitter makes you better and you have no
interest in Pinterest and you don't put the? U in
YouTube, that's alright. you can
just zoom in to the late 90s
and send me an email. you can
email me clarkgreen
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
if all else fails,
when you're out camping, gather
your fellow scouters around a magic mirror,
repeat scoutmastercg
three times in unison
and I will magically appear to answer
all your questions. and by now
it should be abundantly clear
that the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of anybody in particular
other than myself.
we are not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts
of America or any other scouting organization
for that matter. nope,
it's just me talking
into a microphone, trying to lend a hand
to my fellow scouters and have a little
bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun,
here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.